c'est une entreprise historique de saint
quentin en yvelines le groupe socotec a
inauguré son nouveau siège à guyancourt
installé depuis 1979 sur l'agglomération
elle a regroupé ses trois sites et ses
450 salariés sur un espace de 7000 m²
avec un attachement certain au
territoire
alors ce nouveau siège ils représentent
d'abord un environnement de travail
radicalement nouveau pour les 450
collaborateurs qui travaillent ici
beaucoup plus ouvert beaucoup plus
facile temps de travail en transversal
exprimant beaucoup mieux ce que doit
être un environnement de travail
aujourd'hui en 2018 présent lors de
cette inauguration jean michel fourgous
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et marie-christine le tarnec maire de
guyancourt travailler main dans la main
avec les entreprises saint-quentinoise
la volonté des élus vous savez 50 1 c
c'est en fait que j'ai toujours c'est un
trip le pôle d'excellence excellence
sportive ya qu à voir aujourd'hui dans
quelques journaux la ryder cup c'est un
pôle d'excellence économique la qualité
des entreprises à 50 n est plus à
démontrer
elle est assez extraordinaire et puis
aussi un pôle scientifique avec
également l'arrivée de paris saclay la
première université française qui va
être le pôle scientifique et
technologique delà de la france des
entreprises sur une collection une
collectivité c'est très important au
niveau des budgets avec la baisse de
notation effectivement de l'état ça nous
permet d'avoir des financements
importants pour mettre du service public
à disposition des habitants se cotec
réalise aujourd'hui près de 700 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
spécialisée dans les tests l'inspection
et la certification dans le domaine de
la construction et des infrastructures
avec ce nouveau site le groupe a pour
ambition de devenir le leader européen
du secteur